Jim Ryan hit the standing all this
addicts topic sorry Alex have having a
power issue so um take over his topic so
look Jack Brian hit the stand you know
he has a lot of choice to say so I'm
gonna get a bunch of his bars off some
of the keywords not everything so yeah
Jim Wright admits starfield's
exclusivity is not anti-competitive
lawyers ask Ryan Point black if he
believes exclusivity for games like red
4 and Starfield are anti-competitive I
don't like it but I don't view it as
anti-competitive however speaking of the
ABK deal as a whole Ryan said he told
Activision and CEO Bobby kotec he
thought the deal was anti-competitive
and wanted to get it blocked Ryan said
kotik wanted to cover himself with an
extended Call of Duty deal with Sony
just in case things fell through what
Bobby wanted to do was cover himself by
extending the extending the marketing
collaboration between Sony and
Activision in the event of the
transaction not proceeding so a little
slander right there for how Bobby was
moving Ryan and calls Xbox game pass
value destructive he called the
subscription service destructive say
Publishers he spoke it to are not fans
of the model The Game Pass business
model appears to have some challenges
and Microsoft appears to be losing a lot
of money on it I talk to all the
Publishers and they unanimously do not
like game pass because it is value
destructive that was a big eye detector
said why do cops why do cops came
through right at this point that's kind
of hilarious
oh man so look um on August 2020 this
was big August 22 to email from Phil
Spencer's set Jim Ryan's alarm spells
ringing after Xbox announced it's
intention to acquire Activision at 22.
Ryan said Phil Spencer reached out to
him in May 2022 with a potential letter
agreement and list of games Xbox would
commit to keeping on Playstation Ryan
said this interaction with Spencer did
not adequately address his concerns
about activism games on PlayStation
moving forward Ryan also said that he
was concerned about the transaction in
May 2022 but Spencer's response to
Sony's counter proposal in August 2022
set the alarm bells ringing this email
from Spencer caused major concerns
within Sony's camp but the contents of
the email were not shared in court I
actually know the contents of the
evening what's the contest of the email
he sent the email and this is the whole
email and I quote
specifically said that in the list of
games that that Phil Spencer sent to Jim
Ryan yeah if the acquisition comes
through this this is all the stuff
that's going to stay with you right so
Jim Ryan's alarm Bells went off because
he didn't see OverWatch too he's so
OverWatch one Jim Ryan gamer Jim Ryan
realized that OverWatch 2 wasn't on the
list and the alarm Bells went off so
this is no OverWatch one wasn't on the
list no one was what was it that's what
he said so we believe that Microsoft
intends to use Call of Duty to
disadvantage PlayStation in terms of the
availability well the manner in which
the game is made available on
PlayStation consoles and to drive
PlayStation Gamers to the Xbox platform
specifically Game Pass another key point
Ike's on that about Dev kicks and if the
active position goes through so last
week obviously Phil testified that he
said on PlayStation 5 to Sony uh the dev
kits um that Sony sent PlayStation five
developer kits to Microsoft well after
other developers got them Phil also
claimed that the late access to the dev
kits is why there's no native version of
Minecraft on PlayStation 5. Now Jim has
said in his piece for the dev kids that
um that Sony would continue to hold back
Dev kits of future consoles from
Activision if Xbox's acquisition is
completed Jim goes on to say we simply
cannot run the risk of a company that
was owned by our direct competitor
having access to that information that
information could leak into other parts
of Microsoft and potentially allow them
to be able to develop similar features
to the ones that we would argue that we
invented and he claimed that he Sony
could not rely on a contract to make
Activision keep PlayStation features
secret from Microsoft so that was a big
point of contention from him and the
last one which is very interesting was
uh Jim Ryan about Bungie and how he
looked at Bungie versus the ABK deal and
he said Jim said that Sony will get more
out of the Bungie purchase that it would
out of buying Activision Blizzard Ryan
said this lawsuit comes down to Bungie's
expertise in the live service space he
continues to go on when you look at 69
billion for Activision compared to 3.6
billion for Bungie we believe that
Bungie can give us way more than a 69
billion dollar Activision acquisition of
Activision and that's before considering
the relative value of that particular
transaction so I seen you broke without
saying you broke
yo I ask you a question Carl yes
was Jim Lyon oh sorry Jim Ryan
was Jim Ryan lying to The Regulators or
was he lying to his investors he's
running themselves
[Laughter]
he just no because these two things do
they don't they don't go together it's
right it's like The Duality of Man
correct right yeah one side you're
saying we're fine you're saying you're
insulated you're saying it doesn't
matter you're saying if Microsoft wanted
to make an exclusivity play they could
have just spent five billion dollars for
three years of Call of Duty exclusivity
you're saying you don't even know if
they're going to be able to manage it
you're saying they need to do that to
compete that's what you said to your
former boss correct and then you said it
again to your investors at Fidelity
correct but then you went to regulators
and said no this is anti-competitive
right and you wouldn't even answer the
question
if you were Phil Spencer would you do
the same thing correct so he was lying
somewhere I'm I'm just asking the
questions of who he was lying to he
doesn't understand the question he
doesn't he doesn't know
to answer such
um
it's look it's fraudulent Behavior we
just let's just call it whatever we
ain't English called this this is
fraudulent behavior and this is
protecting shareholders and I get it we
know you're gonna do what you got to do
bro so everyone I'm with you on that I
want to start with ksanti just in
general Jim Ryan statements where you at
with that you know there's a lot to
unpack here what did you get for most of
his testimony
oh I I got from from Jim's testimony the
stuff I always get from Jim's testimony
you know he he knows and and I think it
was I was it was on ILP I said I said
this he knows he knows that he has
earned his spot on the Mount Rushmore
snitches
he has earned it I mean am I wrong like
he can now take
he can now
he's talking to people how how David can
poke poke the eye out of Goliath
he said he's up there with Frank Lucas
oh man
but let's be clear let's be absolutely
clear he is doing his job like you know
I I've said this too uh for my for my
soccer fans out there when you see
Ronaldo running on the field and he
grabs his leg you know you don't get you
don't get mad at him when when the when
the referee doesn't give him the call
you get mad at the ref don't hate the
player hate the game against playing the
game that's what it is and and in that
realm he is doing exactly what he's
supposed to be doing and the fact that
he's been able to take a bite even if
it's the smallest piece out of a two
trillion dollar company a company whose
budget he may never see in his entire
lifetime but somehow has made them move
to him as he will
[Applause]
see you obviously obviously he they
haven't he hasn't moved he hasn't moved
them to the place where he wants to move
them but he's moved them enough to where
they've had to go through a lot of
Superfluous processes and like as we as
we've discussed they're they're putting
out they're putting out the uh what they
call the contracts and doing things that
are unusual because he's gotten enough
of The Regulators on his side to the
point where they you got you got place
you got
um Microsoft now doing uh doing
marketing research to discover whether
or not there's there's a outsized
influence on whether it's a positive or
negative for the environment that
they're they're buying things they never
do when they purchase buy their own
admission right and I would I would
argue that's all because of Mr Ryan
right he's the one who's who went out
there did all that and got all of these
ducks got all his Pawns in a row ready
to make them get you to do all this
stuff
yeah he did great work for Nintendo and
Nvidia what did he do for PlayStation I
mean you're a presence though we can't
we can't deny his dominance in that
region and how he really elevated them I
gotta give him that in Europe
that's not what I'm talking about that's
not what I'm talking about which is
great for for Sony okay what Kay's
talking about is what he was able to
accomplish to sort of uh uh uh bother me
the process the deal itself what did he
accomplish in the deal bro give give me
a week we will talk again because you I
guarantee please maybe you can you can
prove me wrong you right now can't tell
me definitively that this is going to go
through
even though you and I are even though
you and I are on the exact same page
because because of what hope law says
you can't account for crazy and not
crazy was stoked by Jim Ryan and all of
that so all of that see you're telling
me that Jim has nothing to do with the
father that has caused this process I
think Jim Ryan was a useful idiot for
people who already wanted to block the
deal but you don't you don't see you
don't think they both used each other
yeah you don't think that he's one of
the persons to ignite the the the only
person that the judge says if Sony would
have took the deal would we be here
that's right and FTC tried to the skirt
around the question and she changed it
again and said again I'm going to ask
you if Jim Ryan did not go to regulators
and bring up this issue and sign the
contract what would we be here yeah be
here yeah she said oh and by the way
this is an inevitable point that we
would have gotten to but you would have
never gotten here without Jim Smith
she said that to the lawyer who was uh
five minutes ago asking about Diablo 4
yeah the guy who used to work for him
yeah
like come on he has put something in to
this process whether he was completely
successful or not you know we we will
we'll see about that we'll see but you
can't take away you can't take from him
the fact that but he has earned his
paycheck he has earned his PlayStation
paycheck for real for real whether he
successfully does it or not he has
earned his paycheck and you got to give
him credit for that right because if you
were in his position this is what you'd
want to have done maybe not oh yeah
everybody feeling it see I I told
everyone once what if Sony buys Sega and
then does a Ratchet and Clank Style
Sonic yeah does it will you forgive them
for that and he's like
it's crazy that'll be his crazy timeline
that would be a crazy time
I wouldn't prefer not to answer that
question oh no yeah you sound like
information you sound like Jim though
fair enough fair enough
this is a fun fact for everybody if you
know your uh Sonic and Sega history
uh uh what's the the the engineer over
at Sony what's his name again I don't
know
yeah used to work for Sega
absolutely and when and when Sonic 2 was
gonna get made he brought yujinaka over
yes to to uh work because he didn't
really want to work in Japan and they
kind of worked together to make that
happen so there is some DNA there but
not so to to answer your question
directly I think he did exactly what he
was supposed to do I think a lot of his
conversation were full of
straight lies right which which I find
quite interesting because you know we've
we've heard a lot of teeth built about
it C-Class Executives cannot lie they
can skirt the truth they can they can
embellish they can you know they can do
a little bit of that bobbin and weaving
that we saw kotek and the rest of them
do this dude you can you can find Point
positive lies in his statement for some
reason that just
true well no yes he was yes he was he
was deposed deposition his deposition
sure sure since he's not the defendant
and they're not yeah so so they deposed
them but then they didn't and then
that's the reason why he didn't come on
he didn't come right because then he
would have to be under oath yes
absolutely absolutely
then that means that means that that's
probably why he's able to skirt this one
on the side good point good point yes at
the end of the day it is what it is you
know you can hate on him as much as you
want you know you can you know and you
can you can you can have issues with how
he made his moves and what he's doing
and all that he's like I've played Call
of Duty games and I'm like I don't
believe you sir
what's your PSN tag oh exactly
that's the art of the snitch man we
gotta respect to snitch game like he's
he's like the Omega snitch right like
and he got a little mini bosses like
Sammy the bull and Takashi oh but he's
like the king snitch like so he knows
how to move like you thought you was
gonna get him on the stand he's like
haha videotape like that's right yeah
and he said it on a VHS tape oh man
because you know they won the war
against betamax it was just little
things and he he makes sure that y'all
understand exactly where he at with it
his snitch game has no parallel
[Music]
I will not deny his snitch game at all
because when did you ever think that a
billion dollar company could could
literally poke the eye out of a two two
trillion dollar company and really cause
as much static as he has right now hey
Asante remember when your mother told
you be careful with your words because
words are power and you were like nah
man people hitting people in the face
hurt right and he was like I ain't gonna
believe her and Jim said he understood
that oh yeah his mom's told him that
words is powerful Jim said yes and he
went to Brazil and said Mira Aki
a moment of your time before Oh bad boy
I can't I can't with you the bad Spanish
I can't moving on if you gotta get these
guys I need to get PK real quick so
obviously Jim Ryan's testimony a lot of
things to unpack anything that's
particularly stand out for you in
reference to his testimony
um
for me you know
because he was
on a recorded deposition and even though
Sony's headquarters is like uh right 20
minutes
[Music]
from you know I mean if you're a snitch
it behooves you to be right next to the
courthouse
I'm just saying this is how slick he is
he makes sure that his
working
where he works at is out of UK so
technically even though he's here he
actually
works out of the UK office so they can't
necessarily ask him to come in I mean PK
though seriously you you had Satya take
a meeting and go sorry president of the
Free World I'll be right back because
these people got to ask me about video
games
honestly but again they're not on trial
here true true yeah very true they're
not the defendant if it goes absolutely
in August that would be different oh
yeah yeah this is just for a restraining
order
so they don't have to show up right now
um however that isn't changing anything
in August whenever they go to court but
uh just to be clear and I just want to
make sure everyone in the chat knows
that everyone listening
um FCC
had the burden of proof not Microsoft
right and they had to burden of proof
not to buy certain not even by certain
just probable cause yes that's all they
had to prove yep not Theory and what
they did was they had a lot of theories
but no evidence to bring probability
I mean even their uh you know so-called
expert had a quantitative data model
that my students can put up right and
you know kids that can put together
and he based it off of Xbox One and PS4
which is crazy to me that you're gonna
use that and apply it here then you put
your own input in that input that it
created you put it to come up with is it
so listen to that Jim Ryan sat there and
it's crazy that these emails came out
and you know someone goofed on
what they not supposed to show I don't
know if that was intentional or not but
no they just use the wrong marker oh
that's Sharpie oh that shot Sharpie gate
discourages
in by positioning the language on if
we
um if we do not allow Microsoft the
access
to our console should they buy this it's
going to hurt our consumers which in
turn hurts consumers that's the language
State or the the method he was trying to
use to position it and
also you know basically he was he was
the way he was speaking was was
obviously he was comfortable he was
being recorded and which means they can
have mass retakes you know just you know
well I don't like that let's do this
again
yo yo I mean
yo run that back run back let me get
that back let me get that off all right
you do the FTC yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
he does I agree with Cog hey he is a
businessman he's doing what he's doing
for his brand and he's he's trying to
put enough doubt out there for this any
any way they can to delay this deal so
like it's all through he's gonna do it
he wouldn't be lobbying if it wasn't
important factor if it wasn't important
we wouldn't even be talking about this
he wouldn't have been there he wouldn't
be in UK he wouldn't be all over the
place trying to
persuade people to go that direction if
it wasn't important and I think the
judge was not only smart enough to but
Savvy enough to understand game yeah she
said that that's why she asked the
question we wouldn't even be here facts
she just said if they signed the
agreement like everybody else would we
they couldn't answer it because that's
not the truth good point that's not why
it didn't matter if they signed the
agreement or not you were pushing this
this Initiative for your own reasons
because someone else came to you and
started pulling coattails and we already
know why they refused to sign contracts
because it's not just because of Call of
Duty they want to guarantee
they get everything and they want
everything they lost he wants everything
and everything he lost and that is
what came out and and what also came out
is hey no one talked about this because
marketing is a huge deal yes the fact
that Xbox couldn't even mention the word
Call of Duty on their show last year
the marketing wait that mate that
position Sony to or or the appearance to
because we're we we are the small few
who are into this right but the Casual
Market they have no idea they think
that's a a PlayStation exclusive yes it
looks like a PlayStation think about
this talk to them how many people know
that Seafood is on Xbox factual talk to
a marketing holds power marketing where
it's whole it is on there but no one
knows because they're not allowed to
Market it that is huge so if they own
the marketing rights to Call of Duty no
longer do they have this narrative like
his next topic about that this is gonna
be fun
and and and he knows that this is what
Jim Ryan knows think about this this is
what no one says that he also asked for
them to
cancel all the contracts with Activision
where they have to pay them back
towards some of this marketing stuff
that they front loaded he don't want to
pay the bills either
nobody's seen that I mean it's there but
the right person I find that
um this is a typical thing and this is
why I don't understand why people get so
in their feelings about
you know because business Biz they're
going to do what's best for their
situation and I do respect that he is he
is he is Savage bro listen people like
yo don't defend foul behavior and I'm
like bro that's business but me
personally I would just say we still
believe in Generations oh and greatness
is still waiting I don't know all right
PK we gotta stop
for the block
we're gonna stop I mean I mean Cog it is
almost four times oh man y'all let the
fireworks go early
when the next psvr come out you're gonna
have to buy everything all over again oh
here we go to the next PlayStation
a super turbo Edition
PlayStation six to get another VR bro oh
babe ever boy do you want to Commodore
okay yes yes real quick real quick
move this along all right so uh the one
thing is that you brought up about how
they could not even mention Call of Duty
on their stage you know what's Wild
Sony was giving them a 10 discount on
for the for the pleasure or the ability
to be able to do that Xbox had to pay
the the same
non-standard rate and they got nothing
for it yeah as a matter of fact they got
worse and they still had to pay Sony's
price so none of the benefits actually
being hurt by it and they they still had
to pay 20 but like the North
Phil never forget
and that is why
he was like okay cool I'm gonna pay you
the 20 but uh
you when he came back to him he got him
but anyway we got to paint the picture
to everyone Bobby kotec rolled into
Winterfell and made the queen been in
need of these turns Queen Sarah ball had
they had to bend the knee and like you
said the north remembers
continue the story this is great and and
so okay you wanted to strong arm us
about this 20 and well you're gonna pull
all your content off the platform
uh your employees just happened to start
coming forward
right oh you just happened I mean we're
a a multinational conglomerate and now
you just happen to be getting sued all
over the world
oh oh your stock price is dropping
Bobby calls Phil Phil don't pick up the
phone oh man
and then Phil then then he picks up and
says this is what we gonna offer you
cash
I'm not even talking to you no more take
it to your board oh babe but anyway
that's not about this we want to talk
about we want to talk yes please uh the
gym right so the thing is this right I
hear a lot of people running with this
idea that uh Jim Ryan said oh Bobby K
was trying to work out a side deal yes
if you believe that Bobby kodek would
put forget about the the 67 billion
dollars or whatever right 68.7 billion
dollars you understand if he had any
conversation like that that would put
his three billion dollar breakup fee at
risk do you think Bobby K is gonna have
any conversation like that to put that
at risk um ever born they're forgetting
the part when Bobby told you I was
trying to reach out to these dudes and
they wasn't calling me back so that
conversation never happened because
exactly get in on the phone to get to
the other side to make the proposal
because Jim was already butt hurt from
the stuff that he did he said how dare
y'all do this and bring this to me how
dare y'all not allow me to little man
this dude no I don't want to talk to
nobody that's a person that sees what
they did and they're ghosting you
looking at the phone he knows what's up
nah and and that's why he said I believe
uh Bobby was trying to work out a deal
he didn't say that that's what Bobby was
trying to do because that makes no sense
at all but he was up there lying the
whole time anyway uh the other piece of
it is when we talk about these contract
negotiations
I I don't know like we I understand it
because
if I don't want this deal to happen why
and I know that if you get my go-ahead
that kills The Regulators there we go so
why should I sign anything unless I'm
gonna get everything true right there's
no reason for me to sign it but if you
want me to sign it cool I'm I'm gonna
take your knees facts yeah right so he
he he was doing what he had to do but
two two Mr K asante's point right all of
this
and at the end of the day from the
beginning of this deal Microsoft said
it's going to take 18 months to close
right we're right at the 18-month Mark
and after this hurdle they can just
close because I think they'll close over
to CMA that would be closing in 18
months they said they were going to keep
the game on PlayStation they're probably
going to keep the game on PlayStation
unless Jim wants to get cute
the the the the the point is all of this
hooting and hollering and and turning
States evidence and doing all of that
and we still end up where Microsoft said
uh we were going to end up and when they
said it was going to happen so Jim Ryan
has only been successful if the deal
gets delayed and doesn't close past 18
months other than that Microsoft said
the terms in the beginning that is the
terms they will continue to get and and
and and and they don't have to sign
anything there's no there's no remedy in
place anywhere in the world that says
that they they have to give Sony any
special terms there's nothing in writing
saying that they have to give Sony
access on the subscription service
there's nothing in writing saying
exclusivity yeah they have to ask for it
that's right yeah and they have to pay
for it when they ask for it right so so
so again all of this that we're looking
at uh uh Jim Ryan like he's some kind of
Svengali what did he really get done
they're closer like they said he got he
dirtied up he dirtied up Pete he got
people to look at yeah he dirted the
waters
Nintendo and Nvidia that's what he did